[Musique]
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors que
dit précisément cette nouvelle enquête
bien cette nouvelle enquête elle montre
qu'au-delà des violences policières qui
il ya pu avoir durant les manifestations
il y avait aussi une certaine violence
juridique d'une certaine façon avec des
lois contraires au droit international
des lois françaises d'exception qui ont
permis par exemple entre novembre 2018
et juillet 2019 de mettre plus de onze
mille deux cent trois personnes en garde
à vue dont 5962 ont pu être libéré sans
poursuites vous dire combien de garde à
vue et bien n'avait pas lieu d'être
autre chose il y à ce délit d' outrage à
agent outrage à agents de la fonction
publique qui peut être soit par des mots
des gestes ou bien par des écrits il ya
par exemple vous avez une enquête vous
outrage ouverte à narbonne en mai 2010
neuf parce qu'il y avait une banderole
tenue par des manifestants qui disaient
simplement en mai oui au muguet non lbd
donc c'est vous dire là aussi un peu
l'ampleur de ce dispositif pour très peu
de choses et rien qu'en 2019
il est plus il ya plus de vingt mille
personnes reconnues coupables d' outrage
ensuite il y a eu ses loi sur les
manifestations non autorisées vous
rappeler lors des actes d gilet jaune
quasiment toutes les rues de la capitale
étaient interdites à la manifestation
certains leaders un défilé jaune n'avait
pas le droit d'arriver dans les
quartiers autour des champs elysées ou
des lieux de pouvoir eh bien rien que
pour ces contraventions pour
manifestation non autorisée
c'est plus de 1000 contraventions à
partir de mars 2019
et puis il y a pire encore c'est ces
lois qui ressemble à minority report où
on arrête quelqu'un pour ce qu'il
pourrait faire dans le futur c'est à
dire participation à un groupement en
vue de préparation de violences et là se
sont fait arrêter de nombreuses
personnes plusieurs milliers là encore
simplement parce qu'il portait des
lunettes de protection ou bien des
masques contrôler les gaz lacrymogènes
certains mêmes qui ont été arrêtés dans
le cadre de ces attroupements en vue de
commettre des violences étaient
journalistes
et là on est vraiment dans quelque chose
de
de graves parce qu on est au delà du
cadre du droit et on est en train
d'attaquer le droit de manifester c'est
ce que dénonce amnesty international si
le coc ville at il renforcé les lois
d'exception
alors oui d'une certaine façon on le
voit et vous en parliez à l'instant avec
toutes ces mesures de fermeture des
restaurants des bars sans trop savoir si
on a le droit encore devoir de l'alcool
en mangeant ou pas où la police ne sait
plus exactement que faire pour mettre
des contraventions
il ya eu les autorisations de sortie
lors du confinement
il ya eu beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui
bien sûr les manifestations publiques
qui sont réduites à moins de 1000
personnes moins de 10 personnes sur la
voie publique donc tout est fait pour
empêcher les gens bien sûr de se
regrouper
là c'est pour la protection sanitaire
pour éviter que le virus se diffuse mais
ce qui est drôle c'est que vous aviez
des lois comme par exemple celle d'avril
2010 9 qui interdisait de se couvrir le
visage est bien celle là n'a plus lieu
d'être puisque aujourd'hui le masque est
obligatoire
donc là le gouvernement ne sais même
plus comment gérer et malgré les lois
liberticides ducobu des biens ils sont
obligés d'admettre qu'on doit se couvrir
le visage et c'est pour notre bien cette
fois ci
et pour conclure cette interrogation
emmanuel macron se posent en défenseurs
des libertés et des démocraties
européennes est ce que vous y voyez un
paradoxe
oui c'est assez paradoxal parce qu'à
l'international emmanuel macron et
président de la france ce pays de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen qui est un peu le far des
libertés à l'international et la petit à
petit et bien les différents pays voisin
où beaucoup plus loin ont vu comment ce
pays le nôtre la france gérait les
manifestations gérer le droit de
manifester ou simplement les libertés
fondamentales et ont peut-être inquiets
et c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs amnesty
international parce qu'il est là des
lois d'exception qui vont à l'encontre
du droit international or la france n'a
pas lieu d'être
et pourtant emmanuel macron bien parade
sur la scène internationale du liban à
la lituanie en passant par le mali pour
défendre les démocraties européennes
pour défendre les droits et les libertés
fondamentales qui sont le projet soit
disant de cette construction européenne
on peut se poser la question quand il
montre du doigt viktor orban
par exemple pour des mesures
contradictoires et contraignantes pour
la presse
ce qu'il en est ici en france puisqu'on
a vu les journalistes empêchés de faire
leur travail
entravés par les policiers qui
demandaient la carte de presse ils n'en
n'ont aucun droit
et puis bien toutes ces lois dénoncée
par amnesty international qui sont loin
loin de l'idéal français de liberté
égalité fraternité
merci beaucoup alexis poulain je
rappelle que vous êtes éditorialistes